c'est l'isolation du pignon entre le
garage et le couloir de la maison avec
son mari anne claire le bas via houdan
depuis 21 ans
trois hivers après leur rénovation
énergétique il économise environ 600
euros par an sur leur facture de
consommation d'énergie la maison date de
donc elle est assez âgée on avait une
grande déperdition de chaleur et elles
étaient chauffés entièrement à
l'électricité radiateurs électriques qui
eux étaient aussi assez âgées penser à
l'environnement et puis on voulait aussi
bas faire des économies au niveau de la
facture d'électricité après l'achat de
ce poêles à granules ils ont appris
l'existence de l'accompagnement sur ce
type de travaux ils ont constitué un
dossier auprès de l'anah résultats sur
les 25000 800 euros de travaux
ils ont bénéficié de 3000 euros du
département et de 12000 euros de l'état
l'isolation des combles donc
l'entreprise a soufflé de la laine de
coton habiter mieux c'est le programme
dont a bénéficié anne-claire le bas
plusieurs critères à remplir être
propriétaire d'un logement construit il
ya plus de 15 ans une aide attribuée
sous conditions de ressources
on fait une double proposition aux
yvelinois à la fois une aide financière
qui vient compléter déjà les aides de
l'anah
il faut quand même savoir que cumuler
aide de l'anah et les aides du
département des yvelines on peut aller
jusqu'à 75 % du montant des travaux
financés par le programme habiter mieux
une deuxième proposition que fait le
département des yvelines aux yvelinois
c'est un accompagnement qui est à la
fois gratuit et neutre d'experts dans la
en la matière en matière de rénovation
énergétique deux opérateurs solia est
cité maîtrise ont missionné par le
département
objectif pour les yvelines accompagné
6000 ménages d'ici à 2023